HE HAS BEEN REMARKABLY GOOD AT
THE FIRST FACE-OFF IN OVERTIME.
HERE HE WILL DRAW AGAINST
LUNDESTROM AND THE WILD WHEN IT.
>> AGAIN, ONE OF THOSE SCENARIO
WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IN THE
GAME.
THEY MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
>> WAS SAVED BY GIBSON AND HE
SCORES.
IT TAKES HIM 17 SECONDS AND
KAPRIZOV WINS IT FOR THE WILD!
WE HAVE TALKED THROUGHOUT THIS
HOMESTAND ABOUT THE FACT THAT
MINNESOTA HAS BEEN ABLE TO WIN
GAMES WITHOUT THEIR EIGHT-GAME
ON THE TOP OF THE LIST.
>> IT WASN'T THEIR PRETTIEST,
BUT SOMETIMES YOU NEED YOUR STA
PLAYERS COMING YOUR BEST PLAYERS
, TO CARRY YOU THROUGH
SOME ROUGH TIMES, KAPRIZOV DOES
THAT.
AND THIS IN OVERTIME.
HE BRINGS THIS IN.
A GOOD LIBRARY THROWS IT TO THE
NET.
AND IT'S AMAZING.
HE MAKES THINGS LOOK EASY.
THEY ARE NOT, THAT HE IS JUST
THAT SOLID OF A PLAYER.